we're in Los Angeles for three days to
attend business con correct yes we were
sent to represent Hampton de Ville at
business coming it's an orgy of
meaningless handshakes and empty
promises tinged with lies and
desperation
honestly it was electric I got my own
lanyard and badge it was Matt's first
business con the first two days you
stayed well within your per diem limit I
pride myself in sticking to a per diem
but on the third day things got a little
out of control didn't even forty seven
dollars over the limit let's start at
the beginning of the day you spent 23
dollars and 40 cents at Cassie's coffee
cart
large coffee oh sorry kid do you have
samples for the scone John Kate one
moment please I'm talking scones all the
coffee in the largest size you offer and
also a Snickers bar in the largest size
you offered I felt like the mother of
three children no woman should have to
experience that I will in fact with a
pound cake how many pounds are in the
pound cake on the bottom just make a
decision cheese danish I deeply regret
not getting the scone it's so obvious
now then there is a four and a half hour
gap between breakfast and lunch what
happened at that time well we just mmm I
don't know Network do you know how it
goes of these things actually I don't
get to go to conventions
enlighten me okay we walk up to people
and you say hi I work at Hampton develop
where do you work oh wow that's
impressive
maybe we should definitely do business
something what do you do your can use
their experience I definitely know what
that is and I think it's incredible
let's definitely stay in touch I'm
desperate to stay in touch please don't
ever stop staying in touch with me oh
look we've been talking for 35 minutes
here's my business card
let me give you my card here's a card
car
gar gar gar gar gar ping me